So I think my favorite app would be Sound Hound.
And basically your out at a party or a store.
And the song comes on and you're like "oh, this
song is awesome but I don't know what it is". And
you pull out the Sound Hound and it listens to
a little bit and it tells you it's Jay-Z and
Beyoncé, Bonnie and Clyde. I can't think of anything about
it that really annoys me. If they could improve it there's
songs that it doesn't recognize. Like they're building the
library the whole time and I'm sure it, you know,
they can make it faster but if say as they're
building their library later on. And it recognizes one of
the songs they didn't recognize earlier if it would
just text me and it would be like that song
that you were listening to eight months ago? This is
what it was and then I, that would be amazing.
>> I think my favorite app is C25K and the C
stands for couch potato and it's basically where you.
>> If you have no running experience, it
gets you up to running 5k in eight weeks.
>> Some of my favorite features in this app is that it allows you to play
music while you're running and then whenever the
app talks to you, it pauses the music.
>> So I never have to worry about running over
the time that it allotted for me or anything like that.
>> It uses the playlists
that are already in my phone, so if I create playlists, like, I
love Justin Timberlake, so I have a
running Justin Timberlake playlist and if I'm
in the mood, then I put that o, or if I'm into like some
nineties music, I have my nineties running
playlist, so I love having that option.
>> So one of my favorite apps is Pinterest, it's a service that
allows you to collect digital images you like and put them into boards.
>> So, there's various uses of it and
personally I've been trying to come up with a visual theme for our website.
>> And I use that board to collect different
images on robots cause that's a theme were pursuing.
>> And I just put them into a board and I can quickly see
like patterns and like, things I like in one place so that's very powerful.
>> And I can use that for inspiration, mobile and desktop across
various different platforms.
>> So, an app that I didn't like that I downloaded a while back.
>> I think it was called SleepBot and basically, it
uses an an accelerometer to track your movements as you sleep.
>> And it figures out when, how deep of a sleep
cycle you're in and wakes you up when you're not in
such a deep sleep cycle. It wasn't very reliable the way
it works is that you say you want to wake up, let's say
at say 6:30 and it'll either wake you up up to 15
minutes before or up to 15 minutes after that didn't always happen.
>> It could have been an hour, two hours or it would just never ring.
>> It's not a good idea when you have a job.
>> [LAUGH]. So last app I remember uninstalling
I think was called Public Bike SF. It
gave you biking routes through the city. So,
San Francisco's a very hilly city and it tells
you like you're going here to here. Take these streets so
you don't have to you know, climb up this crazy hill and
go back down it but I'm not using my phone while I'm
on my bike. So, it was basically just useless and really slow.